hallo Christoph wie ist die Lage mich
würde
interessieren W wer wäre denn eigentlich
dein traumgast wen hättest du wen hat
noch nicht in der Show den du aber
unbedingt gerne mal kennenlernen würdest
egal aus welchem Land Amerika
Deutschland oder wo auch immer ist egal
und zweitens würde ich ganz gerne mal
wissen wie kommt man auf den Namen Klick
Zoom weil ich finde das kommt ich finde
das klingt mehr wie eine kamerasow wei
Klick und Zoom h ja würde mich freuen
wenn die Frage dran kommmt und schönen
Tag noch hallo is 23 welchen Gast hätte
ich am liebsten das ist wirklich eine
sehr sehr schwere
Frage ich kann sie wirklich nicht
beantworten es gibt Gäste da da bin ich
richtig aufgeregt weil ich denke boah
wer ist das denn oder boah das ist ja so
jemand tolles da hätte ich nie gedacht
dass ich den jemals vor die Kamera
kriegt bei Franc potente war das ein
bisschen so bei Hans Klock dem Zauberer
war das so ich weiß nicht der eine hat
den wo er da diese ehrfeucht empfindet
der andere den nächsten m wen hätte ich
gerne ich glaube so auch jemand wie John
lesseter das finde ich ganz fantastisch
also solche Leute die von dem Handwerk
auch erzählen können aber letztlich habe
ich keinen Gast den ich unbedingt wollte
ich bin immer wieder happy wenn ich ein
Gast bekomme natürlich die die am
prominentesten sind weil die natürlich
aufs größte Interesse stoßen ich bin mal
angerufen worden hey willst du Lady Gaga
interviewen das hat aber dann leider
nicht geklappt das wä natürlich ganz ist
toll da wä ich einfach weil das einfach
so ein Ziel ist hey den größten den
einflussreichsten prominenten der Welt
mal zu interviewen m das wäre so ein
Ziel WoW oder Justin Bieber oder sowas
ähm aber das ist dann mehr so ein
Jagdinstinkt muss ich ehrlich sagen hey
ich will den prominenzesten überhaupt
auf der Welt mal vor die Kamera kriegen
jo klickzoom die Frage wie sind wir
drauf gekommen ein Namen für so etwas zu
finden ist wahnsinnig schwierig und wir
haben so lange überlegt und wenn man
sich überhaupt überlegt was gibt es für
Namen für irgendwas Apple Apfel für
Computer na ja ist ja nicht doll passend
oder Sony oder ich weiß nicht was es
alles noch gibt irgendwie passen die
Namen nie es gibt keinen richtigen Namen
glaube ich jedenfalls vielleicht
Deutsche Bank das ist für mich so das
war Name da passt alles auch das Logo
ist super aber das ist wirklich selten
zu erreichen so optimal deswegen wir
haben halt mit klicken und zoomen und
Kamera und sind wir irgendwie auf dieses
klickzoom und das X als verbindendes
Element gekommen und war damit ganz
happy wir wissen es ist nicht optimal es
könnte ein besseren Namen geben aber er
ist uns nicht
eingefallen